Thank You Andre so this is a third talk
in this miniseries but this one is
actually reasonably independent from the
previous two except that I kind of
assumed definition of Markov chains so
what is going to be a bad it's going to
be about the conductor's canonical part
and I'll say a little bit about
canonical flaws as techniques for
improving balance on the mixing time and
we have other techniques like comparison
decomposition and several others but I'm
going to focus on these partly because
my theme for the day is Markov chains on
matchings where they're all matchings or
perfect matchings and canonical paths is
pretty much the only thing that we've
managed to get to work on these to get
reasonable bounds just like what les
they did and linka i'm listing a lot of
people here to thank for contributions
that I'm going to talk about this is
kind of like an air connect collection
because I'm trying to also with the
references on the slides but in case I
forget anybody I apologize okay so
what's going on here I'm going to assume
throughout today's talk that my Markov
chain is ergodic that means that I have
a unique stationary distribution and
just to refresh your memory organic
means that it's a periodic and it's also
irreducible meaning I can go from
everybody to everybody and more moreover
I will mostly assume actually I think I
will assume throughout the talk that my
Markov chain is also reversible so I can
go back and forth between my states and
my picture here these bubbles are my
states
I have transitions I'm not telling you
what the probabilities are but it looks
something like this now when does the
Markov chain mixes we saw Anaya gave
this a beautiful talk yesterday about
using the coupling technique but now
let's kind of just look at this gap and
try to understand combinatorially what's
going on so here it seems like if we
take a walk in this kind of scenario
this is my transition graph they feel
reasonably confident that we could mix
on the other hand if my transition graph
looks like this
especially if my left set is kind of
exponentially large and so is my right
side and I have this teeny tiny
connection between them then even if I
were able to kind of mix in one side
then it would take me and if this is
exponentially a large part then it would
take me exponentially many tries to even
get to this one state to be able to even
move to the other part of the state
space and so this is intuitively not
going to mix and this brings us to this
definition of conductance in other words
it also goes by a [ __ ] constant and
what it is it's essentially the escape
probability okay so for computer
scientists this is kind of like a cut in
a graph so I'm going to look at all
possible subsets of my state and
technicality I'm going to look at only a
substance that are in probability
distribution mass smaller than 1/2 and
then I'm going to look at a state inside
my set that's probability of being in
the state and then probability of
actually escaping outside going to a
state Y that is out of us and I'm
normalizing it by the mass of s so
essentially condition and being in as pi
of x over pi of the all of the states in
the set s is going to be the probability
of X conditioned on being in the set s
so let's see what I mean in my graph
here suppose that I have my stationary
distribution uniform meaning all of my
states are equally likely and this is my
s so I have three states the probability
of s is 3 over 11
smaller than 1/2 and these edges are the
escaped edges and now I'm telling you
what the probabilities are and so now
when I go through this calculation I get
a beautiful expression something like
that and now my conductance for this
specific s is 0.3 here
okay if I look at this one I get 0.02 so
it's much smaller now what does this
really tell me well I'm not going to
prove this theorem but it's possible to
relate the conductance to the spectral
gap okay
and not just relate it's possible to use
conductors to upper bound and lower
bound the spectral gap there's a small
difference the upper bound is a linear
function of the conductance the lower
bound is a quadratic function and why
does this matter
well this is something that we saw in
the first talk the spectral gap is gives
me a bound an upper and a lower bound on
the mixing time okay so now I'm going to
rephrase this theorem I'm going to
simplify a little bit
putting the conductors in and assuming
laziness the theorem can be now
simplified to getting an upper bound and
a lower bound on the mixing time in
terms of the conductance okay so the
goal is if we can bound the conductor's
if we bound it from above we are
providing a lower bound on the mixing
time if we bounded from below
we're providing an upper bound on the
mixing time okay
well that's nice but now the question is
so we really what we want let's go back
what we really want we want to provide
usually an upper bound on the mixing
time so a lower bound on the conductance
that's kind of nice but well sort of so
what happens is if you want to provide
an upper bound on the conductance it's
enough to just look at a bad set s and
compute its little escape probability
the Q of s but if I want to provide a
lower bound that will give me an upper
bound on the mixing time well in that
case I kind of have to look at all
possible SS and find the minimum okay so
how do we go about that and this is
where the brilliant idea of German
Sinclair comes in and that's called the
canonical paths
so what happens again computer
scientists when we hear a cut what is
the first thing that comes to our mind a
flow right min cut equals max flow well
the world is not as beautiful here we
will not have any quality but we'll have
a relation so German Sinclair came up
with this idea of setting up a path in
the transition graph between every pair
of state so for every pair of State now
I'm going to call them I for initial and
F for final so here if I take my INF
over there I'm setting up let's say this
path then I have another one I have
another one I sort of gave up here but
in reality there's a lot of paths here
okay
there's as many as the number of states
squared okay so now what does this
really do well in a way the conductance
is telling me how much probability mass
I can get from a set s to outside and
now canonical parts if I am going to
send a good amount of kind of volume of
stuff from I to F then I will know that
I will be upper bounded by the
conductance and therefore the canonical
part will provide a lower bound on the
conductance okay so now how does it
really work well let's take a set s okay
now I'm going to look at the probability
mass of s which I should have mentioned
before it's just some across every
element in s every state and its
probability and if I take the
probability mass of s and multiply it by
the probability mass of the complement
of us well then what am really getting
is this is just simple summation I'm
summing across everybody in s and
everybody outside and the probability of
the state
as times the probability of the state
outside this is just a definition okay I
mean it comes directly from the
definition of both by offices now the
only thing I've done here is I divided
by the escape probability when going
from s to the outside okay so now let's
look at the left-hand side now my
left-hand side is lower bounded by I'm
going to take s to be the smaller of the
two as an S complement I have a
reversible change so it doesn't really
matter and therefore this quantity the
complement is lower bounded by 1/2 so I
can I can simply write this expression
but this expression is something that we
have seen it's really just a definition
of the conductance and the reciprocal of
that and half but it's definition
assuming that now I'm actually looking
at the small as possible cut s ok so
that's my left-hand side now let's see
what happens with the right hand side
with the right hand side now I can
express this fraction as instead of
summing it was all initial final pairs
one in one out I can look at every
single little edge that brings me
outside state inside as going directly
by a single transition to a state
outside there's my x and y and then I
look at all of the paths that go through
this specific edge okay so the picture
is here's my XY edge and then I have all
these wonderful paths that go through
there okay that's this summation I know
it's a gorgeous expression and now the
bottom is just the same and now it's a
simple averaging argument if I give you
a set of n numbers and I take the
average we know immediately there's
going to be one number that is going to
be bigger than the average or at least
as big right so
the same kind of an idea applies here
I'm going to now take the ratio of just
the inner parts of these two summations
I'm just going to take the ratio of this
and this component and by the averaging
argument I know that there's going to be
an XY pair X Y such that this ratio is
bigger than equal to the average so this
is what I get now this is actually the
end of a proof we will see what we just
proved we proved that one over the
conductance times a factor of 1/2 is
upper bounded by this quantity now what
is this quantity this quantity is there
is some some transition going from
studio to state B okay here's a
transition there's a bunch of parts
going through it they just go go go and
each of these part is taking
contributing a volume of PI I times pi F
okay we are summing all these volumes
and then we are dividing it by the kind
of a capacity of the edge okay and we
will I just took the expression up here
this is what we got and we can call this
as the congestion through this
transition you'll be okay so now what
happens is simply taking this we have an
upper bound on one over conductance and
that it needs you from the previous
theorem that I showed you gives me a
band on the spectral gap and I have a
bound on the running time on the mixing
time okay now this analysis a big part
of the relation of the conductance and
mixing from being kind of like a square
this can be actually improved I'm not
going to use this definition of
congestion I'm going to use a slightly
improved definition of congestion Utah
mr. Sinclair
and it's kind of the same thing that we
had before I am looking at a transition
UV I'm looking at all of the paths that
go through it the paths contribute PI of
the starting point of the path times pi
of the end point of the path but now I
have this additional length of the path
but the actual mixing time bound will
not be a square of this of this value
but it's going to be just a linear
function of this value now one last
thing that I forgot to mention well I
don't even know what U and V are so
instead of figuring it out I'm just
going to maximize and essentially in
words what this boils down to is I'm
looking I'm going to look at the most
congested edge if the most congested
edge is not very congested then I have
rapid mixing oh I forgot to mention I've
been mixing in this context news
polynomial mixing ok ok so an example is
coming but before that here's the
theorem if we found this wonderful
quantity called congestion well then a
mixing time bound that we get is just
four times this value the congestion
times logarithm of 1 over AB sometimes
the smallest stationary probability ok
so that's the framework now an example
is coming so let's revisit matching so I
define matching class time but in case
there's somebody who wasn't here before
a matching is I have a graph I have a
set of edges that are vertex disjoint
and a matching is called perfect if all
of the vertices have an adjacent
matching edge
so let's and last time we talked about
if we know how to sample matching we
know how to approximately count them
okay so the goal that we want to do now
is to just figure out how to sample
matchings now how to sample matchings
well let's set up a Markov chain and
here is the Markov chain
so my state space is all possible
matchings
and I'm going to do the following I'm
Adam a [ __ ] and I choose a random edge
now something like this if my edges in
the matching I remove it if my edge on
the other hand was not in the matching
and it's not adjacent to any other
matching edge I add it in okay now it's
in and now again next step I choose a
random edge
oh this random edge has one endpoint
covered by matching edge and the other
endpoint not covered so what I can do I
can kind of slide this edge over here
okay and they'll refer to this chain as
the sliding chain so we can kind of keep
doing this for a while and as a
technicality I'm going to make this
chain lazy so every other I'm going to
make a step only with the probability
1/2 okay but just for the theorem to be
applicable ok so now the framework that
we had was find a path from any state to
any other state so that we don't have a
very congested transition ok so what
happens here is our states are matchings
so I'm trying to go from matching 1 to
matching to here from red to blue ok
without creating a very congested state
so the very first thing that I could try
is to start in the matching I and remove
all of the edges ok when I say a path I
get to use a transition at a time ok so
I can start with my red matching remove
my first red edge then the second led
edge and so on and so forth and I get to
the empty matching right and then I can
go and keep adding the blue edges all of
these things that I'm describing are
valid transitions of my Markov chain
right so now it's a this is a canonical
path but it's not very good because the
empty matching is super congested
everybody goes there right
to avoid this so instead as Ginga told
us when we see two matchings what are we
supposed to do well we put them together
and we get a set of alternating cycles
and alternating parts so I have these
even like cycles red blue red blue red
wool I just took the symmetric
difference and now what I can do I see
these wonderful cycles and pads and I
order them what do I mean by ordering
them well
the vertices have some labels but let's
let's call these labels one all the way
to end okay so the vertex that has this
the the component the alternating cycle
or pot that has the smallest label
vertex it's going to my first component
then from the remaining components
whoever has the smallest label vertex is
going to my second component and so on
and so forth so I have some canonical
way how to order my component and now
I'm just going to process these
components in this order so I look at my
first component and well what does it
need to process we want it to go from
red to blue right so I have the notation
I'm using here is the straightedges the
non - edges are edges that are in my
current transition okay and the dotted
ones are the ones that are not but I
kind of want to have them in come back
to that soon so now I'm processing the
very first component I know the lowest
label vertex that's my vertex one over
here and it has this red edge and I
don't want it so I take it out and then
what that allows me to do it allows me
to slide the next red edge into the blue
and I go and then the next edge into the
blue and I just keep to do to do to do
around the cycle and the very last edge
I just need to put it in okay so I
process the very first component so now
it's not true anymore that might
edges are the edges that we're okay so
what's happening now my - edges are
edges that either I still want to get in
or I've already prospects and a process
and I don't care about them anymore okay
okay so let's go to the second component
if my component is a path I don't start
with the lowest vertex but I start with
an endpoint and I kind of keep going
flip flip flip until I change red to
blue okay now my path here is kind of
teeny tiny so what it really means is I
just slide my red edge to this blue okay
and I still need to so if my path fare
longer I would keep sliding sliding
sliding until the very last edge if I
needed I added it okay now I do the same
thing in my third component and I go
like this so the beautiful part think
the beautiful thing that happened was
that I actually haven't used any of the
other edges except for the edges in my
matchings and at any given time it was
kind of close to one or the other of the
matchings okay so I'm going to now try
to formalize this oh but before that I
know you really like this expression for
the congestion so let's look at it again
so now what really happens is what we
want we want to figure out how many of
my alternating cycle flipping pads go
through any given transition okay but
now I am actually at a symmetric chain I
can if I slide I can slide back if I add
an edge I can remove it and vice versa
so my stationary distribution is uniform
meaning the probability of any matching
is 1 over the total number of matchings
which simplifies this wonderful
congestion expression quite a bit
because 1 over PI of I PI of F are each
1 over Omega
and it's the same so when we cancel
things out what we really are left with
is just 1 1 over Omega then we have to M
for the probability of the transition
because we're choosing a random edge and
we're doing it lazily and then we have
the length of the path and the length of
the path
well how many transitions do we need to
go from red to blue well we're just
going through the edges in the matching
and so the number of the length of the
pot the number of transitions I need to
go from red to blue is upper bounded by
the number of matching edges and so
that's n okay but now if you look at
this simplified bound well when Lily
happens is and comes to the to MN over
the size of Omega meaning over the
number of matchings
and this summation now just boils down
to the number of canonical path through
my transition okay so what I want to
bound is the number of canonical paths
for my transition and in particular I
want to bound it by the number of states
and possibly times the polynomial factor
if you think about how many canonical
paths I have have all possible starting
States all possible final States so I
have number of states square canonical
parts right and I want only number of
states canonical paths to go through my
transition okay
so let's see what happens here is my
transition ok it incidentally happens to
be a transition that we've seen in my
little demo and just to reinforce it
what we want we want to show that the
number of number of pairs of red and
blue matchings that goes through my
beautiful wonderful purple transition is
going to be bounded by the total number
of matchings okay so essentially what
happens this is a purely combinatorial
argument now
we are going to show that's the case and
let me show you when did we see this
transition we saw it when we've already
processed the first component we're
processing the little path okay so in
reality I'm going to now reveal the
colors of these edges of your semi
transition doesn't know who is blue who
is red it's just happy matching that is
being shifted to another happy matching
but we do know who is who and we knew
that the situation looked like this okay
so now let's look at the complement of
the transition with respect to the
original and the final matching okay
in other words I look at well in my case
I don't really have any any common edges
I'm just looking at the union of I and F
Union of red and blue and I look at the
edges of the transition took that out
and what am I left with
I'm left with my dash edges which are
forming a matching right okay so and
this is another brilliant idea actually
how to use canonical path this matching
this I union F to start matching the end
matching - the transition let's call
that an encoding now in what sense is it
an encoding okay let me only highlight
this so I have this this orange encoding
well I kind of want to say that it
encodes the path that we got it from
okay so the situation that we have now
is I know the transition that I'm trying
to figure out how many parts go through
that transition that's my purple now
somebody gives me this orange and says
well if I give you this orange that you
know there is one path that kind of
corresponds to this purple slash orange
combo and so this orange information
would encode that path
okay so the question is can we now look
at purple and orange and figure out who
used to be red and he used to be blue
okay and it's actually not too difficult
to reconstruct I an ad because look at
the cycles and the paths those are
exactly the same cycle and paths exactly
the same components that we had before
the components themselves do not depend
on who is colored red or blue so we know
the components and now we know that
we're making a transition in the second
component that means that the first one
must have been already done and since
the first one must have been already
done that means that the edges that are
in the transition have been already
switched to the final matching to the
blue one and the edges that are in the
encoding the other ones have been taken
out so they used to be red okay now we
can do the same thing for the third
component because we know it's coming
after the one that we're processing so
now the purple the transition edges
haven't been taken out of the red yet so
they have to be red and the other ones
are the blue ones okay and now the final
thought is what happens with the
component that I'm currently processing
processing and there we know what has
been done before the transition that I'm
looking at what still needs to be done
and based on that I determine who is
supposed to be red and who is supposed
to be blue okay so the bottom line is we
showed we were able to reconstruct this
situation so we from the encoding from
just somebody comes and gives me a
matching and from that I can figure out
the two matchings that are moving
between and I'm going across the current
transition okay so what that means is
actually with me I think I had a slide
on that so what this means is that the
number of matchings through my
transition
is and he said again the number of paths
through my transition is bounded by the
number of matching right every path is
encoded by matching and therefore what
we wanted was to upper bound the number
of paths through transition by the
number of matching is possibly times a
polynomial factor and we did that okay
okay so well except that I kind of
didn't quite tell the truth because
there is one other case that I just want
to very briefly point out what if still
the same transition but now we would be
actually dealing with the following red
and blue pair so now the components look
different right for different red blue
pairs the components look differently
even though we are going through the
same transition okay so now if we try to
encode this red and blue pair we still
process a look at who is first or second
component we get the encoding as taking
the Union or symmetric difference after
red and blue we remove the purple edges
the transition and we are left with this
orange but now is this matching well not
quite it's almost a matching except for
this one vertex because it just so
happens that I'm processing a cycle and
if we are kind of flipping a cycle there
is this one case where we have two edges
that are not in but there is a very
simple solution we can simply remove one
of the edges excuse me make this into a
matching so now I have the orange
matching and now I claim but this is
good enough because what I can do if
somebody just gives me the yellow or
orange the encoding in this case well I
can look at my component I can figure
out who is first or second I can figure
out who is blue and who is red in the
prior component
I can figure out who is blue or red in
my current component but there's one
minor teeny tiny detail which is I do
not know whether my current component is
a path or whether it was a cycle and I
removed that one edge okay
so I don't know whether it was this
scenario or this scenario but it's
actually very easy because I just
remember one extra bit in my encoding
okay so when it comes to I instead of
encoding I just remember zero or one and
so then instead of bounding the number
of parts by the total number of
matchings now I bound it by twice the
number of matchings okay so the
take-home point here is when you want to
use canonical pads you're trying to find
a way how to move from one state to
another state without congesting any of
the transitions and what does it mean if
we are in the uniform distribution this
criterion really means the number of
paths through any given transition is
supposed to be bounded by the number of
states times possibly a polynomial
factor and how do we bound the number of
hats by the number of states but we kind
of want to take a path and encode it
into a state okay okay so now that being
said what we got for the sign transition
we got the upper bound on the number of
canonical paths as twice the number of
states we still need to analyze two
other transitions one is the ad
transition and the other one is the
remove transition but I'm not going to
do those but we can do it the same way
and so what it boils down to is a band
on the congestion of roughly four times
MN if I didn't make a mistake and that
gives us a bound on the mixing time and
that in turn gives us an F cross a
randomized approximation scheme using
the product of the ratios that we this
last time okay well now what's most of
perfect matchings
so what happens here the Markov chain is
very similar except it's now not going
to move on the state space of all
matchings but it's going to stay within
the state space of perfect matchings but
it's kind of hard to move from one
perfect matching to another perfect
matching so instead it's going to go
through all perfect and near perfect
matchings okay
an imperfect means that I have exactly
two vertices that don't have a matching
edge so they're kind of like the holes
okay so what it does here I have a
perfect matching now I am going to
choose a random vertex is just a small
modification to speed up the chain to
decrease the probability of the
transition so I'm choosing a number tags
if it's adjacent to a matching edge I
take it out now and that introduces two
holes to uncovered vertices and now I
again choose a random vertex and I
choose one of the holes and now if the
vertex has matching edge I get to slide
it to the hole provided that there's
actually an edge between my chosen
vertex and the hole that I chose so in
that case I slide otherwise I don't do
anything and if I happen to choose a
random vertex which is equal to my hole
and there is an edge between the two
holes I add that edge to my matching
okay so very similar chain except that
now I have these two holes that are kind
of moving around and sometimes I add an
edge between them okay so the analysis
of this Markov chain is very similar to
the previous one the canonical paths are
kind of the same with one small
exception which is well if okay if we
have a path between a perfect matching
and a perfect matching
they told us that if we take two perfect
matchings we have wonderful alternating
cycles and we just do it exactly the
same way as before if I'm going from a
near matching to a perfect matching
then the picture looks something like
this
I have alternating cycles and one
alternating path and now I kind of need
to process the alternating path at the
very end because otherwise otherwise it
would be introducing and other halls not
during the time and I'm processing when
I'm moving from my red to blue but when
I'm doing the encoding part okay I'll
show you what I mean so I have the
components and I do the flip flip flip I
would have fixed the first component and
maybe I would have fixed the second now
this is not what I'm going to do I'm
just kind of showing you what would have
happened if I process the path before a
cycle and now I'm processing a cycle so
I need to flip cycle number three
component number three from red to blue
and so what happens is I would have the
purple transition and when I look at the
encoding I would have the yellow
encoding when looking at red and blue
taking purple out so I'm left with
orange and now we see that we have one
two three four holes so the encoding
would not be in the state space that I'm
working with because I'm working with
only perfect and near perfect matchings
so I wouldn't be able to use this to
bound the number of paths by the number
of states in this way okay but if I if I
process the path last it doesn't happen
I'm fine now there's one other
technicality what happens when I go from
near to near then I kind of don't really
get to avoid this issue I would have had
the four holes no matter what but the
solution is not to even try so what that
means is instead of even defining these
paths
so here are my near matchings and here
are my perfect and we know take your
favorite near matching take your
favorites perfect we know how to go from
near to perfect right
so now I want to go from my
near matching number one to my near
matching number two so I'm going to go
to a perfect matching the way I know how
to do it and then from the perfect to
the other near again oh I know how to do
that but how do I choose this perfect
well you can kind of think of it as
randomizing across all of these perfect
but now this is the time and I'm going
to introduce this idea of a canonical
flow instead of a canonical path so a
canonical path is supposed to be a path
from an initial state to a final state
but I don't really need it to be a path
for the arguments to go through this
part is completely okay if it splits as
long as the total mass that it sends
from the initial to the final is PI I
times pi F okay and so with this same
logic and all the theorems and
everything goes through so with the same
logic what I can do is when I go from
near one to near to I kind of split
myself to go through all possible
perfect matchings with equal portion and
then I come back to the other needle
matching and what this boils down to is
that my running term now gets multiplied
by a fraction of the number of new
matchings over the number of perfect
matchings because that's the
contribution of the additional by going
through the perfect okay so this is nice
if we can bound this number of near
perfect matchings to perfect matchings
by a polynomial factor then we have a
polynomial algorithm for sampling well
for sampling what that's a good question
well what if my graph my input instance
looks like this
well how many perfect matchings are
there like one
because the entrants have to be an HS
coach that it is just one perfect
matching but how many near perfect
matchings are there well if I leave the
end points unmatched then I have
exponentially many near matchings every
mile every one of my little boxes has
two choices so even if I were able to
improve the analysis on the mixing time
if my goal is to be able to sample
perfect matchings this wouldn't have
helped because it's like I have one
thing that I'm trying to find randomly
in exponentially many other things it's
kind of like looking for a needle in a
haystack I just wouldn't be able to do
it the good news is that there are some
graphs for which the number of near
matchings and perfect matchings the the
ratio of these two is bounded by a
polynomial factor by polynomial function
and for example the dense graphs would
be such a class of graph okay so well
let's try another Markov chain so this
Markov chain is only going to work on
perfect matchings okay so now i'm
getting rid of the near issue no near
matchings just perfect matchings and
this is the so called swap chain
sometimes created to die agonist and
rangoli in a different context in the
context of contingency tables so the
swap chain what does it do well choose
two random edges like these two I am
choosing them giving them the vertices
names because based on which vertex is
chosen as the first and we just a second
that's how I'm going to do the swap that
I'm about to describe
so now choose two random edges and swap
ok like this and Wow you might
immediately suspect that there is
something something funny going on well
if I choose these two random edges I
can't do the swap so I don't that's fine
that's kind of like a little self look
staying within the same state but still
there is a bit of an issue
if my input graph looks like this I
can't really move there is no way how to
get to the other perfect matching but
let's look at if my input graph on the
other hand looks like this one then you
can verify that there is actually way
how to go from any perfect matching to
any other perfect matching okay
so that's this Markov chain mix rapidly
do we have a polynomial time mixing time
our bound on this Markov chain provided
that we have an infinite set on which we
can actually go to all of the states
okay well well maybe not so look at this
instance it's kind of inspired by the
example that we saw before we have the
chain of boxes as what we had before and
then we have one other edge connected in
this specific way and now if I match the
bottom two vertices to each other I have
only one way what to do with the top
right now if on the other hand I do not
match the bottom two vertices to each
other I match them to somebody up up
there then I'm kind of I have only one
possibility of how to do the matching
edges on the left of this left edge
connected to the bottom vertex but I
have many possibilities between the two
horizontal vertical lines okay so now I
claim that I can I can actually go from
any matching on the left to the matching
on the right and it kind of just you can
verify it very quickly that you can do
that so now I have a connected Markov
chain I have an irreducible instance ok
but the number of matching is on the
left is exponential the number of
matchings on the right that is just one
that matches the bottom two vertices
okay so I'm going to use this
sort of a gadget if I'm a sort of a
gadget to actually show that this swap
Markov chain doesn't always mix in
polynomial time okay
in this case the case that I'm just
showing you where I took the previous
graph and I repeated it four times in
this kind of in this configuration the
swap chain does not mix rapidly it
actually needs exponentially many steps
to get to the stationary distribution
for this instance and how does that work
and this is the reason I wanted to go
through this example we get to use the
conductance to actually provide a lower
bound on the mixing time okay so the
game that we are playing is here's the
definition of the conductance on the
left over here we can easily notice just
by the analysis that we saw before that
if I look at matchings that look like my
left scenario where a look at the four
middle vertices and they're matched to
the left and the right part which forces
matching in the top and in the bottom
okay and I have exponentially many
possibilities on the left and right so
there's exponentially many
confidentially many matchings of the
left kind the same argument holds for
the right kind now I have the four
middle vertices and they're matched to
the bottom and pop which forces the
matching on the left and night and I
have exponentially many such matchings
but the way to move from left to right
is to get the four vertices matched to
each other and then flip them and that's
how we get to the right so really my if
I if I kind of look at the geometric
properties of my transition graph I have
exponentially many guys on the left
exponentially many guys on the right and
just one connection between them and so
when I look at that connection which
corresponds to exactly this set for the
conductance I get this expression
and so there's only one edge that gets
me out of us which is flipping these two
edges this way and so I get an
exponential after BAM well exponentially
small upper bound on the conductance
which gives me an exponential lower
bound on the mixing time okay okay so
now the last part of the talk Oh
the example that I took here there is
this related problem called contingency
tables and binary contingency tables I
took this example from a table with an
antenna and then I Rando but if you want
to learn more about the swap chain and
in which scenarios it's going to work
there is a very nice recent paper by our
German Miller okay so now the last part
of the talk is talking about the
permanent okay so just to remind you the
permanent is likely determinant but
before got the minus one part so and I'm
not going to actually get into this
definition but if you think about it if
a is your adjacency matrix you're just
going to count the number of perfect
matchings in a bipartite graph okay so
that's what I'm going for
try to figure out how how many matching
perfect matchings are there in a
bipartite graph if you recall we know
how to count all of the matching is
approximately that's what we did in the
first part of the talk okay so the
trouble is that my favorite chain of
boxes instance is bipartite right so
even if we could improve the mixing time
analysis of the sliding chain that we
had before we would have this picture
just like what I said before but now I'm
showing it pictorially right we
discussed we have one perfect matching
that's my blue portion over here and we
have exponentially many other guys well
we don't like that but okay let's
analyze the situation situation a little
bit further okay so the idea of jerem
Sinclair and V guna
still well to change this picture okay
so we see how that works so if we
analyze the situation a little bit
further so the blue ones are the perfect
matchings and then we have all of these
matchings with a specific pair of
uncovered vertices kind of with holes
you want to be okay so this is my holes
at you and me this is another pair of
holes and so on and so forth so I have N
squared for the number of holes plus one
different regions one is for the perfect
matchings well I don't like this picture
my blue one that I really want is
exponentially small but I like this
picture I kind of want to really weight
this the the picture so that I do not
have my regions so different sizes but I
want them to be roughly equal okay if I
know how to do this then well I will
simply sample from this state space and
we probably roughly 1 over N squared I'm
going to see a perfect matching right
okay
so what I want is every matching before
it had uniform before I had a uniform
station be uniform stationary
distribution now I want to adjust the
proportion for a near matching if I have
a near matching bit holes at the U and V
I want to adjust the stationary
probability by the weight of number of
perfect matchings over the number of
knee matchings and if we now think about
the calculation what we get it would
have changed the picture this way okay
now well there's only one problem we
started from the problem of trying to
count the number of perfect matchings
and now we're trying to figure out the
weight of number of perfect matchings
over the number of near perfect
matchings with holes at U and V so it
seems like from a bad problem that we
went to a yet even more difficult
problem right
but don't despair there is this is our
gem Sinclair vigoda's idea there is a
way how to go about this so if my target
graph looks like this okay it's a
bipartite graph but actually doesn't
really have to be for this picture but I
have a target path and I do not know how
to compute these weights
well let's simplify as Florin told us
yesterday so if he starts with an easy
graph we know how to compute the ratio
we know how to compute the number of
perfect matchings over the number of
near matching with holes I do you want
to be right okay will will actually let
me see if I have it here what happened
oh okay that was supposed to happen
okay so we will start with an easy graph
like the complete graph I'll show you
what the computation of the weights is
in a second and then we will gradually
remove the edges that we don't want okay
until we get to the after being like so
if we start with an easy graph the
complete graph we know that the number
of perfect matchings over the number of
new machines is n factorial now this is
the time when I'm using bipartite - it
don't really have to for this but let's
do that so I get n factorial for the
number of perfect matchings in the
bipartite graph okay over number of n
minus 1 factorial now what I'm going to
do here I'm going to add weight to the
edges the edges in the target graph are
going to stay at weight of 1 but the
edges that you almost don't see the ones
that I kind of gradually removed I'm
going to give them this activity or for
our physics friends that kind of a
temperature analog that is going to
start at 1 and then it's going to get
decrease and decrease
and decreased until we fade it away okay
this is very reminiscent of the
annealing process we started a high
temperature and then as we cool down
well high temperature supposed to be
like messy but easy and as we cool down
we get to the state that we want to be
at okay so now what happens is with the
lambda in instead of doing the number of
perfect matchings of a number of new
matchings now I'm doing the lambda
waiteth variant of this okay so what
this means is for I'm always going to
work with the complete bipartite graph
but now some edges will contribute this
wonder factor so once my lambda factor
gets teeny tiny it's almost as if the
matching that uses a lambda H didn't
exist okay
I should have told you what the weight
of a matching is it's just product of
the of these weights
either ones or the lambdas okay okay and
so now with this understanding we have
an estimate on the ratio that we want
for lambda equal to one and now we can
use sampling well actually even before
that and then what we can do is we can
keep the following invariant we will
start with lambda equal to one we know
the weights and then we will keep
decreasing when I'm done and the
invariant that we will keep is that any
given time at any given time we will
have a four approximation of the weight
for my current lambda then I will use
sampling for this lambda to improve the
approximation factor from four to two
let's say and that allows me to decrease
my lambda a little bit and what used to
be a two approximation factor is now the
four approximation factor for my new
lambda at a high level does this make
sense
so for approximation boosted using
sampling to to approximation and then
decrease lambda would used to be a to
approximation is for approximation keep
doing this
it turns out the number of lambda steps
that we need is actually not too bad
it's only about analog square and what
it comes to is actually what it comes to
is proving that my Markov chain with
this weight actually mixes rapidly and
it uses a similar canonical path
argument okay but now I have to throw
the weights in so things don't cancel
out as beautiful as before and I also
want to point out that there's kind of
two different weightings going on
there's the lambda waiting for the
contribution of the matching itself but
then there is also the adjustment that
I'm doing with the ratio so that I don't
get this remember the circular space
that was kind of very different region
sizes I need to adjust with the current
approximation of the weights so that I
get the space kind of nicely partitioned
into roughly equal size and squared plus
one regions okay so I think I kind of
stopped here I'm not going to get into
the analysis of the mixing time but if
you think about it and so this is the
result budget of jerem Sinclair and
begorrah there is an F browse for the
permanent and if you think about it
everything that I said about starting at
the complete graph and computing the
starting weights and fading away the
edges none of this really required a
bipartite graph I could have started
with a complete non bipartite graph I
could have computed the starting weights
and so on and so forth so the
requirement for the bipartite Ness comes
from the analysis of the mixing time
okay and essentially it kind of boils
down to if you take if you take some
alternating paths and I give you a
guarantee on an edge additional edge
if you have a bipartite graph when you
take two different alternating paths and
connect them with edges you're going to
get an even length cycle then you can
done beautifully decompose into two
matchings but if the graph is not
bipartite you do not have this guarantee
anymore and that's where the analysis
breaks down I'm just going to very high
level leave it at that so let me get to
the last slide so I guess the biggest
upper travellin that I would dare to
consider a biggest of a problem in the
area is to figure out what to do for non
bipartite graphs thank you